and whenever you find things that you're
comfortable doing you're going away from
the journey of life the way I continue
to stretch myself
at my old and tender areas I'd encourage
good people often become seduced by the
chatter of Thoreau loudest fears wanna
be happy build a life not just the
business
hates every Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you two
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn why your
comfort zone is destroying your life and
how to get out of it
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one escape the comfort zone with David
Goggins whenever life will start getting
good for me God would throw an ice
anchor and stop me right there
so I'm going with your pair rescue
training and there's this evolution
called
water confidence in water confidence is
pretty much what gets people kicked out
special you know Special Forces Special
Operations at the water and they try to
drown you pretty much this was not in
the warning order so I didn't know
anything about water confidence long
story short what it is is they put 16
pound weight belts on you whatever they
can do to make you uncomfortable in the
water so for six weeks of a 10-week
program I became very uncomfortable we
got down to about 25 30 guys left I was
one of them and getting near graduation
this program thinking my god I'm about
to get through this barely though water
confidence is killing me right they took
me to medical they they they drew my
blood and realized I have sickle cell
yeah so sickle cells of blood disease
that some african-americans have it
which is not good no so they took me out
training for a week and when you go from
being uncomfortable that's your
lifestyle you get used to being
uncomfortable right when you go back to
being comfortable your mind says I don't
want to go back to being uncomfortable
again that's right
sounds like I don't want to go back to
the water so my whole mindset was I want
to get out of this training so I was
hoping that they're gonna medically
disqualified me from pair rescue program
that didn't happen a week later the doc
called me in the office said hey guess
what man we're gonna put you back in the
training I was like okay well I missed a
week I got about two and a half weeks
left I can do this I went back to the
you know to the CEO the commanding
officer he said hey guess what we're
gonna start you back from day one and
when he said that to me my mind went
back to the Oh
David Goggin so I thought I'd changed
yeah Laurene learn how to swim learn how
to read and write all I was doing was
attacking the surface I wasn't getting
down into the dungeon of what was really
bothering me so whatever like tough
times would happen you know any tough
time that really tough time that
happened I would go back to the sewer of
my mind so this happened I went back to
Lyon I said hey you know what Co this
guy being of a doc didn't know about
sickle cell he didn't give me a good
reason why it's not about sudden death
heart attack stroke I'm not comfortable
so he gave me a medical from pair rescue
so he allowed me to leave but I really
quit I didn't want to go back in the
water again right and that's when I went
from weighing 175 pounds to 297 in about
three and a half years Wow so I did a
job called tack pee yeah control and
fast movers behind enemy lines but that
job wasn't a job that I wanted and the
spiral of depression yeah of trying to
find things that I was comfortable doing
and whenever you find things that you're
comfortable doing you're going away from
the journey of life and I was going so
far away from my journey that my weight
showed my whole mindset rule number two
step outside your comfort zone with
jockle willing I'm a chef in a large
operation kitchen recently during my
last review I was given some advice by
my boss and his boss they said it was
important for me to give up some of my
kitchen dog mentality and work to
showcase my artistic side and embrace
more of a star role in the spotlight get
out of the kitchen a bit more gain more
exposure specifically with our
high-profile clients should I heed their
advice or stick to what I do best and
keep getting after it on my terms
those questions it's just funny how how
that last statement is framed right I
stick to what I do best and keep getting
after it as if to say if you say no you
should not stick to what you do best
yes lane you should not get after it
right that's that's the frame
there and actually this guy I answered
the question real tersely I think this
came through Facebook messages so you
know I said sounds like you found a
comfortable zone for yourself and you
want to stay in there the right
cold-blooded response and he's like I
knew it because as we know when the
comfort zone ders there's no growth in
the confidence if you really don't want
to do it well then you can keep being
the guy that's in the back and guess
what you're gonna be mad in six months
when some other chef gets hired for a
different shift and all of a sudden he's
out making friends with everyone he gets
promoted and why does he get promoted
well look what the guys doing but he's
not as good as he's not as good as it
Cooke as I am guess what they don't
really care
hmm being making the food is only part
of what they want you to do just like
being a seal doing doing missions is
only part of what they what you need to
do to do the mission yeah
you can't just be tactically sound
you've got to have the relationships
built so you can work in the battlespace
that's owned by a conventional commander
you got to have the relationship that
you can get your missions approved up
the chain of command on a special
operation side how do you do that you
build you go out you talk to people you
get out of your comfort zone also if you
want to have more motivation self-love
and confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the links to join are in
the description below you can outwork
anybody how bad as they are and I looked
at him and I said I'm not a brand I'm a
person stop resisting I encourage you
stop resisting the natural flow of epic
performance stop resisting the natural
seasons of life rule number three push
yourself out of your comfort zone with
Dane Pena the way I continue to stretch
myself at my old contender
[Music]
stratosphere in Las Vegas 855 feet now I
have artificial knees artificial hip
artificial shoulders I have no right
long head bicep from bummed up from
various things that happening so I
should not be jumping out about 855 foot
town then I got a man like this so my
lovely wife said damn why don't you go
watch the people and keep sleeping about
seeing land and I don't we jump know
anything ain't no negative so I go to
the top and I go well I didn't write on
YouTube we cut out the part of you
falling on my head in Boise man into the
cement and because my knees couldn't
take the pressure till I pulled me
transplant
a couple years ago both knees but I
continued to do stuff like this to
continue to push myself outside my
comfort zone and if I'm pushing myself
outside my comfort zone in my 70s it
could be now I'm not suggesting any jump
off buildings I'm not suggesting any of
those things but what I'm suggesting is
the older you get kids and this is
directly to the the harder it is to push
yourself outside your comfort zone cuz
then you got a fan you got kids
you got a mortgage you got your mother
and father then take care of you got a
half half-breed [ __ ] eating for a
sister or a life that with you and rule
number four the last one before a very
special bonus clip is be comfortable in
the unknown with Robin Sharma one of my
brain tattoos that I'm become very well
known for is no one will believe in you
until you believe in you and so good
people often become seduced by the
chatter of Thoreau loudest fears and
what I mean by that is we come up with a
great idea let's say it's to start a
pride
that will allow you to lead your feel
let's say it's an idea for a new product
that will allow you to grow new company
let's say you come up with an idea for a
new painting if you are an artist let's
say it's an idea that will allow you to
take your fitness and your wellness and
your longevity to a whole new level of
Wow and pretty shortly after you come up
with the idea
your ego starts screaming because we are
good in our comfort zones but the moment
we start to go blue ocean around our
next level of mastery our fears come up
because we're going out into the unknown
it's human you know if you were looking
to look at the psycho biology of it and
you are study the pure biology that
there's a term called homeostasis human
beings are hard-wired for a steady state
and that kept us alive so literally our
heart beats around the same amount you
know the 72 beats per minute and our
blood pressure is within a small
bandwidth and that allows us to survive
but what happens is when we come up with
a new idea and when we see a new
opportunity and we start to leave our
comfort zones into the zone of the
unknown where greatness lives we get
scared and the true heroes and the true
Titans and the true masters those people
are not fearless those are people who
have just practiced walking into their
fear and living on the razor's edge
consistently to the point where they're
comfortable amid their discomfort now
that's the great opportunity for you not
to avoid fear but to be comfortable in
the unknown to be comfortable when
you're terrified and that really is what
the great artists the great
entrepreneurs the great titans and the
great masters are very good on doing so
the first reason good people lose is
their faith is not as strong as their
fear or to put it a bit more elegantly
their fears are larger than their faith
and so it would be tactical for you how
do you build more faithful you you do
what you're a frightened to do and it's
practice you know a great athlete
practices every morning and a great
producer practices walking into their
fears every single day and what I'm
encouraging you to do is every single
day do one thing that causes your palms
to sweat every single day start training
your brain to hunt for opportunities to
step into that unknown where possibility
lives and if you keep on doing it you're
literally gonna build some new
neurological hardwiring a new mental a
new pathway in your brain where you
become it becomes easier because as you
know so well all change is hard at first
and it's messy in the middle and it's
beautiful at the end now I have a
special bonus tip from Dan lock and how
to get out of your comfort zone that I
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions let's go from just
watching a video to taking action here
we go question number one where do you
need to get out of your comfort zone
number two what's the first step that
you can take today to start building
some momentum and number three who in
your life can hold you accountable so
that you continue to follow through I
think safai you know I don't need to be
the ambitious but that's the problem
your income zone is your comfort zone
your comfort zone is your income zone
when you get complacent when you get
comfortable you are not growing remember
when you're not growing you are dying so
do you have this Eagle that is holding
you back right now and what are you
gonna do about it
if you want to learn how to never be
lazy again check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I was able to find strength in
every molecule of this earth I'm able to
be in a room with nothing with no
motivation or inspiration nothing and
find it